Sinon, il y avait des enregistrements.
J'y ai fait mes premières armes.
Toutefois, ils ne contenaient que certaines informations,
tout comme les cassettes,
ou cet objet ancien qu'on appelle CD.
Sinon, il y avait des livres qui ne marchaient pas.
Voila comment c'était.
Aujourd'hui, on peut s'étendre,
se coucher sur le plancher du salon,
siroter du bourbon,
et apprendre toutes les langues qu'on veut
avec des logiciels tels Rosetta Stone.
Je vous recommande Glossika aussi, un peu moins connu.
Vous pouvez pratiquer n'importe quand
donc vous pouvez le faire plus et mieux.
Vous pouvez profiter de vos plaisirs matinaux en diverses langues.
Je lis quelques « Dilbert » dans plusieurs langues chaque matin ;
cela peut augmenter vos compétences.
Ce n'était pas possible il y a 20 ans.
L'idée d'avoir n'importe quelle langue
dans votre poche
à partir de votre téléphone,
aurait semblé être de la science-fiction même pour les plus erudits.
Alors, je vous conseille fortement
d'apprendre par vous-même une autre langue que celle que je parle,
parce qu'il n'y a jamais eu un meilleur moment pour le faire.
C'est tellement amusant.
Cela ne changera pas votre mentalité,
mais ça va certainement vous épater.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)